Hier ist er der mysteriöse Gitarrenmann aus
den USA. Es ist gut, dich zu treffen. Ja, danke, dass
du Click Zooms in meiner Talkshow mitgemacht hast
, und wir haben ein Treffen hier in
London, und du sagst, warum kommst du
aus Amerika, Mann, eigentlich
Google oder Youtube  Sie brachten mich
wegen einer Art Panel-Sache hierher, ja, ich
werde mir Fragen stellen, okay, also
fangen wir mit den Fragen an, okay, wie
läuft
es?  und dein Cello,
ich glaube, als ich es das letzte Mal überprüft habe, hatte es
ungefähr 1,5 Millionen von allen und etwa
unter 75 Millionen Videoansichten.
Wann hattest du eine fantastische Idee,
so eine Art Idioten zu machen
?
Weißt du, ich habe angefangen,
solche Videos mit Klonen zu machen, wie du weißt,
ich rede hier, stell eine Kamera auf das
Stativ, wie hey, wie läuft es da drin,
hey, mir geht es gut, es sind nur einfache
Sachen und dann du  weiß, dass meine Bearbeitung
gerade ein wenig geworden ist  bisschen schick luftig und ich habe gesehen,
dass es neue Tricks gibt, solche Sachen,
aber ein bisschen nach
und nach habe ich gelernt, und wann hat Ihr Erfolg begonnen,
wenn es alle Abonnenten sind
?
Das Video, das ich herausgebracht habe und das
anfangs wirklich erfolgreich war,
hieß wirklich Gitarre unmöglich, wo
ich in Stop-Motion spiele,
und doch ist das das erste Video, in dem
ich diese wirklich beliebten Hallo und
jede Region herausgebracht habe, aber ich denke, obskurer Vogel,
ich ok ok  Nein von den Leuten ist eine gute
Maßnahme. Ich werde es versuchen, aber du
hast für jedes Video neue Ideen, die ich versuche
Die Leute kommen immer wieder. Wie hat sich dein
Leben seit deinem Erfolg verändert? Nun,
du bist das Einzige, was ich tue. Du
weißt die ganze Zeit
auf
der Straße in den USA, äh ja, weißt du
Manchmal kommen Leute auf mich zu und solche
Sachen, aber ich mag das nicht, weißt du
, weinender Teenager, nein, es ist nicht Justin
Bieber, wie nein, ich bin nicht nur ich und Alec,
Juli, ich weiß, ich wünschte, es wäre Justin Bieber, als
wäre es vielleicht die Brille  oh ja
okay naja wir haben die ganze zeit die brille ich
denke ja ja die meiste zeit mach ich mir sorgen
warum deswegen naja ja ja
okay und es ist halt ein teil von dir kennst
familie ich bin für mich schwierig weil
ich auf dieser platte war und  Ich habe nach
dir gesucht und ich glaube, ich konnte mich nicht sehen, ja,
es ist lustig, denn wie Leute mögen so
die tatsächlichen Prominenten, die du kennst, gehen
aus und sie setzen Sonnenbrillen auf und versuchen,
sich hier zu verstecken, weil ich versucht habe, mich zu verstecken und
meine Sonnenbrille gut abzunehmen  haha
niemand kann mich jetzt kennen yeah okay okay
was sind deine nächsten schritte ich weiß nicht
ich werde sagen auf einer reise solange ich
kann ich liebe es zu tun
und ich liebe es das zu tun was ich hier tue aber
du weißt ich weiß es  Nichts hält
ewig, also fange ich an, du weißt schon
, Musikvideos für Werbespots zu machen  Eos, die so
hart waren, ein Paar zu sein, haben sich in
Bezug auf Krebs geirrt, also was ist
dein Ziel? Ich weiß nicht, ich habe mich für diesen
Typen gemacht, sie kommen hinter mir her. Wir werden sehen,
wo wir schneiden
Oh andererseits vielen Dank Jungs
danke mr.  Gaeta Mann Joe, ich kenne mich gut aus